this is the coolest hosting thing I've
ever seen happen so you and Dolly ACM
Awards y'all just hosted the acorn modes
together that is incredible
I was I was thinking back in my memory
banks and I don't know that I've ever
really seen you all do something
together never had I was scared to death
like crazy to me it's crazy she's all of
four foot eleven and she looks like
she's eight foot tall when you made her
right that picture you just showed the
picture I I feel I need to explain that
picture the very first photo we took
together she could you would you stand
up with me sorry the very first photo
was put together she turns like this and
then she grabs both of my hands and
tells me to place them here oh you're
going to prom oh
yeah
that wasn't what I was thinking
here I said no I can't and then we
started laughing and that was the that
was the shot that they that they used I
don't know if you've noticed but there's
a there's a little difference with me
and Dolly so my mind didn't go there
God didn't bless this
um it blessed so much you know so so
wait so Dolly has said that when you're
together you're the more serious one do
you agree oh yeah yeah she's so cool
they were up there and they go okay
we're gonna do photos right and now
photos aren't boom
boom now photos just boom and I swear to
God man when she go okay here goes boom
boom boom like
that kind of thing right and I'm like
holy
what am I gonna do right and so when
they go okay photos here we go boom boom
boom boom that's all it was all it was
was just chins for days it's like oh
this is horrible she's fabulous you just
described me and Blake Shelton at the
voice photo shoot I am literally like
what will get me out of here and I'm
like oh my God
I'm like the whole time everyone and he
literally in every photo is like Hands
In Pockets like here in Oklahoma it's
amazing
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]